[Music]
welcome back so we're talking about the
singular value decomposition x equals
you Sigma V transpose and now we're
going to talk about how you can use this
to compute the principal component
analysis the PCA which is one of the
most important techniques and
dimensionality reduction in all of
statistics and data analysis it's been
around for over a hundred years and I'm
gonna walk you through just a little bit
of the basics of how to use the SVD to
compute PCA for a couple of data
examples so you can teach a whole course
on PCA I mean there's over a hundred
years of papers and books written on
this I'm just gonna scratch the very tip
of the surface of this in this lecture
okay so a couple of datasets I'm gonna
I'm gonna work with two datasets one of
them is going to be a manufacturer data
set where I have some random variation
in my data and then the other one is
going to be a real-life data set with
genetic markers that correlate to
ovarian cancer okay so in this first
example this is just kind of a cooked up
example this is all the code is that
data book UWM I believe this is all from
section 1.5 of our book data-driven
science and engineering so just walking
you through this very briefly this is
again any time you're going to test a
mathematical tool like the SVD or PCA
it's a good idea for you to to test it
out on a system where you know the
answer so here I'm gonna cook up toy
data where I know exactly what the
variances and statistics of that data is
and I'm gonna verify that PCA if you
just handed the data to someone you
could use PCA to mine that data for
those features so what I'm going to do
is I'm going to cook up a data set that
has a center so my date is going to be
centered at the point it's a
2-dimensional data set there's two
variables X 1 and X 2 the Centers of
those will be two and one the Sigma the
standard deviation of the first
direction will be 2 in the standard
deviation of the second direction it
will be 0.5 so it'll have kind of four
times more variance in one direction
than than the other direction and then
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
rotate this cloud by an angle of Pi
over three okay I'm gonna have 10,000
points in my cloud and I'm gonna
generate all of this so the first thing
I'm gonna do is I'm gonna build a big
random normally distributed random cloud
of gaussians kind of this big Gaussian
cloud in X 1 and X 2 then what I'm going
to do is I'm gonna stretch it
according to Sigma I'm gonna rotate it
according to our and I'm going to Center
it move it centered according to X see
so I think that's actually what I'm
doing here okay and then I'm gonna plot
that cloud of noisy data for you
in the first panel then what we're gonna
do is we're gonna act like we didn't
know that what the rotation and the
Sigma and the X entered was and we're
gonna see if we can learn that from the
singular value decomposition if we can
learn kind of the principal components
the principal axes of variants of this
data set just from the measurements of
x1 and x2 and that's what we're gonna
plot in in subplot one to two so I'm
actually gonna bring the whole the whole
plot up all at once to start with and
then I'm gonna talk you through this
okay so this is my my data set here that
we generated in MATLAB and so again it's
a kind of a Gaussian and normally
distributed cloud of points where what
I've done is I have moved the center up
two to one so you can see here that the
center is not at the origin it is
elongated in one direction more than the
other by a factor of four and it's
rotated up at an angle of PI over three
so this is the data I generated and what
we're going to show is that when we do
the principal components when we
subtract the mean and we normalize the
variance and we compute the SVD then the
principal components these use and
Sigma's will tell me exactly what are
the kind of magnitudes of variance in
these principal directions and what are
their angles with respect to x1 and x2
okay so let's actually let's actually do
that let's see if I can make this a
touch smaller okay good okay so all
we've done up until line 16 is just
generate and plot the data that's the
first left subplot and
everything after line 18 is computing
the principal component analysis based
on the SVD okay so remember the first
thing we do is we compute the mean
vector the mean of all of this data the
mean x1 and x2 position and that should
be very very close to the actual x
center to 1 vector that we added to the
data to offset it okay so that's X
average we're gonna subtract off that X
average from every row of our matrix I
do that by creating this X average x
ones matrix where every every row is X
average and then I'm going to subtract
that off of my data matrix X to get this
mean Center and matrix B so all I'm
doing is I'm taking this data and I'm
shifting it so that centers at the
origin the next thing we're going to do
is we're going to compute the SVD of
this B matrix and we're going to
normalize it by the number of data
points okay so essentially what we're
doing is just dividing by the square
root of the number of measurements
remember we had 10,000 measurements here
so I'm gonna divide by root 10,000 or
divide by 100 so that essentially I'm
normalizing so that as I add more and
more data points my SVD doesn't change
okay so I'm gonna compute this SVD and
now I have my factors u Sigma and V from
from the SVD and we're going to
interpret the U columns and the Sigma
matrix in terms of how this data is
rotated what are the what are the angles
or kind of the vector directions of
these principal axes of variants in the
data and how much variance is in each of
those directions okay and I'm gonna do I
think you should take some time and
actually walk through this code
carefully yourself because there's a
little bit of nuance here what i'm doing
here is i'm taking this theta vector
which is basically just a vector from 0
to 2pi in a small increment and a
hundred increments and I'm gonna take
that circle and what I'm gonna do to
that circle is I'm going to multiply it
by Sigma I'm gonna stretch it out and
I'm gonna rotate it by you so remember
my data had my data was stretched by a
factor of four in one direction or
two in one direction and point five in
another direction so my Sigma matrix
should capture that 20.5 stretching of
those principal axes and I rotated my
data up by PI over three that should be
captured in this unitary rotation matrix
you this should be a rotation by PI over
three okay and so if I take kind of a
Gaussian cloud of points or a circle if
you will and I multiply it by this Sigma
matrix to stretch it into an ellipsoid
and then I multiply it by this u matrix
to rotate it up that's how I'm color
coding how I'm getting these cyan
ellipsoids that I'm plotting here on top
of my data distribution so the and you
can interpret this very physically if I
just take u times Sigma times a unit
circle that is the ellipsoid that should
capture exactly one standard deviation
of my data so you can see here this
inner cyan circle here that's the one
standard deviation circle one standard
deviation of my data is within that
ellipsoid okay it's one one standard
deviation confidence interval and so
what I'm doing here is I'm plotting my
I'm offsetting by my average and then
I'm adding kind of these standard
deviations circles one standard
deviation two standard deviation three
standard deviation not circles
ellipsoids
okay and you can actually see that it
very very nicely captures these ten
thousand data points I get almost almost
all of them within these confidence
intervals and they're aligned with the
directions of maximal variance within
the data okay so that's super important
so these columns you I'm also actually
plotting those directions as these red
lines so the first column of U is the
first red line is the direction of the
maximum variance of the data
corresponding to this factor too so most
of the variance in the data is in that
direction that first red line the first
column of U the second column of U tells
me what the second direction of maximal
variance is that captures all of the
remaining variance this
point-five so really really useful tool
and it has this incredibly nice
interpretation in terms of the
statistics of the data okay so this has
been used for over a hundred years it's
a very very powerful technique but we
can also apply it to real-world data
sets in fact that's why it's useful I
can apply it not just to 2d scatter
plots of truly Gao and data I can plot
it I can use it to analyze really really
really high dimensional data with maybe
hundreds or thousands of pieces of
information and maybe millions of
independent experiments or measurements
of those factors so here we're going to
look at this data set the ovarian cancer
data set this is built into MATLAB so
you can load ovarian cancer and you'll
get this really nice data set I'm just
gonna load everything here and we're
gonna see so what we have I don't know
if you can see in the upper right we
have groups and observations and so
observations is a two hundred and
sixteen let me just do size of OBS we
have a two hundred and sixteen by four
thousand matrix and what this
corresponds to there are two hundred and
sixteen patients and for each of those
patients they measure four thousand
genetic markers okay and what we're
trying to do is figure out which genetic
markers most correlate to whether or not
those 216 individuals do or do not have
ovarian cancer and so this is actually a
label dataset in this in this variable
group GRP which is a two hundred and
sixteen by one cell so if I do size of
group it's a two hundred and sixteen by
one cell and this has information for
each of the patients about whether or
not they have cancer or are normal okay
so again size of my OB s so for each of
those 216 patients we have a label half
of them have cancer half of them do not
and for each of those patients we have
four thousand genetic markers so what
we're gonna try to do is figure out our
patterns in those 4,000 genetic markers
that are highly correlated with ovarian
cancer and this is where it gets
interesting because for a human you
can't plot in a 4,000 dimensional
feature space I can't visualize all of
these features to see if there's an
ovarian cancer cluster and a non cancer
cluster and that's why we're going to
use principal components so what we're
gonna do is essentially take the SVD of
our observation matrix we're going to
take the singular value decomposition of
this big matrix and what we're gonna do
is we're gonna plot the first three kind
of eigen genetic sequences so we had
this x equals u Sigma V transpose U is a
matrix that has the information that's
the same size as people like this is a
216 by 216 matrix V would be a 4000 by
4,000 matrix and so if I plot the first
three values of this V matrix
those are my eigen genomes my eigen
genetic sequences they're linear
combinations of these genetic sequences
but I'm only gonna plot the first three
dominant ones and we're gonna see if any
patterns or clustering emerges and
moreover what I'm going to do is I'm
going to plot those points so each of
these 216 people will have V coordinates
these eigen genetic sequences they have
their own unique kind of genetic
fingerprint in this coordinate system
and I'm gonna take the people that have
cancer and plot them with red X's and
the people that don't with blue circles
and of course I'm inverting the color so
they won't be the same color okay and
we're gonna see if any patterns emerge
let's do that okay so this is what we
have here and again I think the colors
got a little bit mixed up so I should
probably put a legend on here legend the
first one is cancer and the second one
is the normal group let's hope that
works okay
I think it's gonna be a little hard to
get this to work exactly on the first go
but maybe the point I want to make here
is that the yellow and the blue dots
separate in this three principal
component space okay so one group has
has ovarian cancer the other group does
not and just by taking this massive
massive data set and computing its
singular value decomposition instead of
looking at 4,000 numbers for each person
I just have to look at these three
numbers in the v1 v2 and v3 columns
these eigen genetic markers for each of
those people you can rotate this around
and actually see kind of what this data
looks like there are there's pretty good
separation between these data sets you
could kind of draw a line you could draw
a line kind of between these these
clusters and at least with some
probability you'd be able to predict if
someone does have cancer or does not
have cancer based on where they fall on
that line so this principal component
analysis or the SVD is really really
nice for visualizing very high
dimensional data like genetic data where
you can't plot in 4,000 dimensions but
you can extract the first three kind of
principal components or singular vectors
eigen genetic sequences and you can plot
in that space where things might
actually cluster and separate so very
very useful you can also plot the
singular values so again I always
recommend that you plot the singular
values on a log scale and then the
cumulative singular values to see how
much energy is in each of these each of
these principal components and here you
can see this is exactly what I want to
see in my data there are a couple of
massive singular values and then
everything else is really really small
and what that tells me is that most of
the variance in my dataset can be
captured by just a few of these
principal components or singular vectors
and I can kind of ignore a lot of the
other ones and still do a pretty good
job of approximating my data you can see
here the first principal component this
is the cumulative some captures 55% of
the variance of this data so really a
lot
information just in that first eigen
sequence okay so the SVD can be used to
compute the principal component analysis
which can give you some information
about the distribution kind of the
statistics of how data is distributed
what are the principal directions of
variance and the directions that have
the least variance and the most variance
and you can apply it to visualize and
understand very very high dimensional
data okay thank you